[Music]
with sam picking up the shield there's a
lot of trepidation it's surprising how
timely this series is it's been an
emotional experience there's all kinds
of actually complex issues dealt in this
that are very applicable to the times
that we're in it really does make you
feel like you've stepped into something
that's bigger than you
the goal was to be very grounded so that
the super side of it became embedded in
character
we were inspired by a team that flies
through canyons we spent several days
pushing people out of planes
there was a lot of thinking that went
into how to get you into puerto rico and
to figure out how to make it work
seamlessly with the stuff that we shot
in prague
let's roll again i'm on to be here with
all the toys and with the actors who
bring it all alive is just absolutely
overwhelming
we can't be having this much fun
marvel studios assembled the making of
the falcon and the winter soldier
original special streaming tomorrow and
all episodes of the falcon and the
winter soldier are now streaming only on
disney plus